neben dass du blöde glotze die wann sie
kritik mit der mutter / neulich gucke
ich ganz entspannt den polizeiruf aus
rostock eben hobbykeller klar weil oben
guckt renate ja sonntags pech und macht
sich dabei die fußnägel da muss ich mir
leider immer die pulsadern aufschneiden
wie gesagt polizeiruf rostock in einer
szene sieht man die beiden kommissare in
ihrem büro und das ist voll gekleistert
mit anti nazi plakaten und aufklebern
und ich denke noch so das ist ja eine
unrealistische scheiße der film speed in
rostock und die bullen sind legal 30 und
später shitstorm bei der ard
die afg und jetzt kommt die junge union
heulen rum linke propaganda
dafür muss ich gebühren zahlen
und statt zu antworten ja genau müsst
ihr ruft hier nie wieder an ihr penner
was machen die eier losen luft von der
die die reduzieren den aufkleber stars
herzhaft und entschuldigen sich quasi
noch die mediathek in einigen sehr
kurzen sequenzen war unbeabsichtigt
anklamer antike als die aufkleber zu
sehen
ich weiß gleich und selbst in meinen
2006 dar
kunstfreiheit eine fiktive figur kann
jeder partei gut oder schweizer denken
viele dinge tun die fdp ist mir egal
und damit das land zeigen wir jetzt den
von euch zensierten aufkleber
bildschirmfüllend
doch alles nicht wahr sein hätten sie
doch erst mal gesteigert aus seinen
blöden tatorten raus wenn das schule
macht was kommt denn als nächstes
wir leben immer noch in einem final ihm
das du blöde glotze bieten sie für die
nicht gerne was nicht
[Musik]